grieving
outraged determined
brianna taylor's family are indignant at
a grand jury's decision not to charge
any officers with her death and they
have a stark message
for the attorney general did he present
any evidence on brianna taylor's behalf
or did he make a unilateral decision
to put his thumb on the scales of
justice
to help try to exonerate
and justify the killing of brianna
taylor
by these police officers
release the transcripts
twenty-six-year-old brianna was shot
dead by police in her own home after a
raid went wrong
a mother deprived of her daughter and
she says
justice the officer who told a lie to
obtain a search want filled her
the judge who signed the search warrant
filled her
the terrorists who broke down her door
failed her
the system as a whole has filled her
you didn't just rob me of my in my
family you rob the world of a queen
i want to maintain faith in the fbi
somebody's got to give us justice we
can't continue on the streak that we're
going in in america
in this city it deserves to be played
out in the criminal justice system the
way that it should
as the family fight for accountability
others
look ready for war rifles army fatigues
on guard in a car park this isn't the
u.s military in louisville
it's a far-right group known as the oath
keepers
who claim they were invited here by
business owners we were the guys on the
rooftops in ferguson protected
both businesses and apartments in fact
we're here also protecting residents we
don't want to say who they are
or where they live because they're
afraid this they claim is all about
keeping the peace
but there's no tranquility on show here
you
take your friends out of here what does
the presence of your gun do
i mean clearly people are aggravated uh
well it's for self-protection there's
one thing but we've made a promise to
people not to let the buildings be burnt
down and we won't
[Applause]
for those that march the focus is ending
police brutality
and systemic racism they've been doing
this for more than a hundred days and
they say they're determined to keep
doing it
until they see it change and so this
nightly ritual continues
a constant game of cat and mouse with
police
it's hard to see a resolution here
without some radical change
for lynch sky news louisville kentucky